how did you start you're from Queens
right I'm from Queens yeah I don't I
don't I wrote a song like I started
learning GarageBand when I was like 16
when it came out yeah and I was really
into like making hip-hop beats and I
eventually learned logic and label in
Ableton so I I wrote that song when I
was like 19 and like in college and six
years later I was working at like a
publishing house and it was like it was
a kind of shitty job and my boss like
someone was like let's make us a video
let's turn in the video and I was like I
can cuz I like work at this job and it's
embarrassing and I'm trying to like you
know and so he's like warning just wear
glasses
my boss ended up finding out about it
and then like kind of fired me no
so you Clark click entered it yeah yeah
I lived off unemployment and got like an
off the book John which was
right I was a guy got I was in a vegan
bodega that wasn't lit but just like
being able to get unemployment yeah how
you do the system yeah that's it taxes
you know taking in that employment and
yeah which I just say it was like you
know the it had like 8,000 views that
time and then I just started going viral
that's odd
so that went viral right and then in
your heart at that time do you think I'm
gonna be you know a pop like a singer or
did you or because you're more your do
you do everything now yeah I mean I
don't know what to think of it I thought
that maybe as people did find I'll be
like a kind of a tan mom kind of
situation you know or people will be
like she's Asian yeah and so I didn't
really know but a lot of older women
really seem to enjoy it
yeah like like Midwest housewife yeah
and I guess at that time like the
landscape of the internet was so that a
video like that could go viral where I
don't think now I could
what cuz the copies it's like
what year was that then that was 2012 23
and so then you did that and then when
to talk your talk show stop right after
that yeah I mean yeah like pretty much I
got I got approached because like I
guess people saw me as this kind of like
Internet like a vine or kind of person
right when I come not so I but I feel
like that's how people like you know I
that came about and yeah after that like
I got on MTV and the show called girl
code yeah I was on that what do we know
Oh JJ catyph right oh right
yeah Jade talks about you all the time I
loved you and then Esther ku was she on
that I think so yeah yeah was that the
same year yeah yeah yeah
we love her love you Esther he's the
best she's the best she is the best
yeah um we talked about her life
[Music]